hey everyone this is gq recommends we're
gonna break down the four essential
suits you need to cover every dress code
[Music]
whether it's a wedding whether it's a
job interview whether it's a baby shower
whatever you're going to these suits
will get the job done
cleaning classic
these are the suits that you want to
start with that are going to look good
for almost any occasion anything short
of black tie formal you can wear a suit
like this too it's not too loud it's not
too crazy and you're going to look
smooth you're going to look suave you
want to keep things dark and you want to
keep things elegant a suit like this is
as classic as it gets the lapels aren't
too wide they're not too skinny the
pattern isn't too strong it's not
overpowering it's going to go with a ton
of different shirt and tie options the
suit is actually from the 50s i bought
it vintage for like a little over 150
bucks and
minus some very small adjustments it fit
me pretty perfectly and it's going to
fit me well for the rest of my life if
you keep things in that darker range of
tones your blacks your navy's your
charcoal grays those suits are going to
be as versatile as possible asap rocky
mr rihanna himself he is an absolute
style god he loves to go freaky and
funky with his style but right here when
he keeps it classic he shows that even
the wildest dressers look good in a
plain black suit if your style tends to
run a little more idiosyncratic and you
feel that black or navy or gray feels
maybe a little too safe then you could
try a brown suit which is another very
neutral color that goes with a lot of
things brown is definitely something
that we would consider more of a new
classic if you're looking to buy your
first suit you could start with a black
suit you could start with a navy suit a
great place to look for something like
that would be a place like reese it's a
british company they make very classic
tailored stuff at very affordable prices
this one is a great example of a suit
that won't break the bank but will also
not ever go out of style another great
place to find an affordable suit is j
crew j crew has long been the standard
for great american suits that don't cost
a lot of money this is a great example
of a clean and classic navy suit that
will go with everything that is a nice
weight for the spring and summertime and
will last you a really really long time
another great mid-range option still
clocks in under a thousand dollars which
is a really great value for a suit of
this quality is something from sid mash
burns these are the kinds of suits that
you would have seen guys like jfk wear
they feel presidential if the suit isn't
making you feel presidential when you
wear it don't bother buying it if budget
is absolutely no option for you then the
place to go for a suit of this nature is
tom ford he is a fashion mastermind his
suits are regularly on red carpets all
over the world he spares no expense on
the finest finest tailoring these suits
look so razor sharp when you wear them
they look like they were molded to your
body and that's worth the cost of
admission even though that cost of
admission is pretty prohibitive
[Music]
light and breezy
so light and breezy suits probably more
of a summertime situation so you're
thinking lighter fabric cotton linen
maybe a combo of both so the occasions
you might want to wear a light and
breezy suit destination type weddings
garden parties yeah garden parties would
be great you know you can dress these up
or down you can pair it with a vacation
shirt you can rock it with a polo maybe
throw on some canvas sneakers another
thing to keep in mind when you're
wearing suits like this is that because
the fabrics are so light they're going
to wrinkle and that's just something you
have to get used to young is wearing a
nice cotton suit from alex mill under
500 for the jacket and the pants on a
light and breezy summer garden party
situation this is perfect if you're
looking for something in a sort of
middle of the road uh price point todd
snyder is a great option we've got this
guy right here in a nice light olive and
lightweight cotton fabric a suit like
this is going to stand out a little bit
more than a khaki suit but it's going to
go with just as many things if you
really want to show out for whatever
occasion you're going to this fear of
god suit is if i see you on the street
applause it's made from this really
lightweight sort of silky crepe fabric
so it's not prone to wrinkling like a
linen or cotton suit but it's still
lightweight it's still breathable it's
got this great relaxed silhouette a suit
like this it's like so luxurious in
avant-garde that the flowiness of it
does a lot of the talking for you
funky and loud
funky and loud suits are suits that'll
make a serious statement regardless of
where you're going the cut could be
super unusual it could be voluminous
donald glover for example is wearing an
asymmetrically cut double-breasted suit
again with that telltale slight flare at
the bottom and he looks fantastic the
texture could be interesting like the
suit that kyle's wearing here the color
could also be the differentiating factor
it can be super outrageous or
extravagant light blue in particular
will complement you regardless of the
occasion i don't know if there is a
swervier suit wearer today more than
harry styles the king of funky and loud
tailoring so harry's suits are cut
fairly distinctively you'll notice at
the bottom they finish with a pretty
heavily flared leg opening which is a
design flourish we've seen more and more
brands doing nowadays the most important
thing to remember is that if you're
going to someone else's wedding it's not
your day so you don't really want to
steal the spotlight that being said if
the dress code is ambiguous enough then
feel free to take some creative leeway
with the mandate so because this is a
funkier and louder suit you have a
little bit more leeway to get a little
funkier and louder with the adornments
that means instead of wearing a tie like
i am here you could wear a t-shirt like
kyle is here or for that matter a silky
button-down and a knit polo so if you're
looking for an ideal funky and loud
mid-range option you should go to a
brand like needles which makes the suit
that kyle is wearing today it is
absolutely nutty there are these very
subtle polka dots going up and down the
entire silhouette it's got these brash
peak lapels so big you could land an
airplane on them and in general the
pants taper down to a bit of a flare at
the bottom which lends the whole thing a
bit of a 70s decadent vibe this is a
suit that it's almost criminal not to
dance in this might sound surprising but
some of streetwear's best and brightest
make an incredible statement suit you
can go to supreme which routinely
releases a handful of really eye
grabbing tailoring pieces every season
or a place like stucy
which will be able to outfit you with
the same sort of vibe if price isn't
much of a pain point as you can imagine
there are plenty of options like this
beautiful double-breasted version from
drake's what's great about this is that
it's actually a not too distant relative
of the suits that we talked about
earlier what makes this a little bit
more of a statement is the subtle shadow
plaid and also the cut here another
great double-breasted option with a very
different cut is this one from jerry
lorenzo's label fear of god so unlike
the drake's option we were referencing
earlier this one's
somewhat different because there's only
two buttons here which is very unusual
in most double-breasted silhouettes
having a boxy silhouette like this alone
is something that will always make a
statement without blinding people's eyes
we've got a great light blue option here
from the australian tailor patrick
johnson like the drakes and fear of god
suits we were talking about before it's
also double-breasted and has these
substantial peak lapels it's made for
bust in a move
[Music]
mix and match
[Music]
mix and match is about taking different
pieces and styling them with uh
different trousers or sport coats that
you either
have in your wardrobe already or finding
grails out in the world this is where
you can have a little bit more fun and
have more room to really show off your
personality you probably have a navy
suit you probably have a gray suit turns
out they go well together so you can
kind of really get a few more looks with
just two suits one thing that could make
it a little bit trickier but also more
fun
is to play with the different tones and
colors and textures so a great starting
off point would be with uniqlo used
relaxed fit suit comes in a
variety of neutral tone colors black
khaki gray the jacket alone is only 90
bucks so it's very affordable for those
who are looking to step it up a tier the
stucy sport coat is the way to go it's a
little bit more boxy a little bit more
stylish still black so you can add this
with any trouser you could do a nice
dark charcoal pant with it and it would
look great but i might do something
on the lighter side like what kyle's got
on this is also a great jumping off
point for some patterned pants too so a
nice like check or striped pant would be
great for this so for another great
mid-range option engineer garments makes
a nice lawrence jacket goes with
everything very neutral at a higher tier
option we have this mr p charcoal blazer
it might look kind of plain on the
surface but you know for this category
this is a really great starting point
that's gonna get you really far
so that was it for today thanks for
watching you can find all of my favorite
suits all of our favorite suits in the
description below